i thank everyone who acts in support of
ukraine in support of freedom but the
war
continues the acts of terror against
peaceful people go on one month already
that long it breaks my heart
hearts of all ukrainians and every free
person on the planet
that's why i ask
you to stand against the war starting
from march 24th exactly
one month after the russian invasion
from this day and after then
show your standing come from your
offices your homes your schools and
universities come in the name of peace
come with ukrainian symbols to support
ukraine to support freedom to support
life come to your squares your streets
make yourselves visible and heard say
that people matter freedom matters peace
matters ukraine matters from march 24th
in downtowns of your cities
all as one together who want to stop the
war the war of russia is not only the
war against ukraine its meaning is much
wider russia started the war against
freedom as it is
this is only the beginning for russia on
the ukrainian land russia is trying to
defeat the freedom of all people in
europe of all the people in the world it
tries to show that only crude and cruel
force matters
it tries to show that people do not
matter as well as everything else than
make us people